many people come to me and they say how
courageous they see me and very often
maybe in a shocking way I said but I
don't find myself courageous I I find
myself passionate and I love what I do
and if I love what I do I'm gonna do it
all day long
and if I do it all day long I probably
will be very good at it zone and that's
the story of my life I started I was not
born in the circus for example where the
wire walkers are so I learned by myself
as I was learning all my arts magic
juggling the high wire writing books
making films all those things I realize
maybe by looking at performers and also
by becoming one that the most powerful
way to inspire people to touch an
audience is not to try to touch them is
to be yourself if you write a novel for
what the people want to wait while you
do a writer that I will be uninterested
in but if you write because you are
Devore inside by a fire and then you
need to write or the painter needs to
paint then then your work will be
interesting and actually some people may
hate it or my love it which actually a
distant cousin it's much more
interesting than people says oh I don't
remember that work of art but you will
cause a human response much more which
that if you try to please if you try to
you know in in performance in show
business and I hate that term you see
people on stage a juggler a magician
they try to make the people love they
try to make them applause and by doing
that they take away from their arts you
have to find your own personality own
style and that takes sometimes a
lifetime or you can copy people and
that's you know a an artistic crime but
to go the easy way and to try to be a
crowd pleaser
at a very young age in my life I
realized that was a form of artistic
three